- [grunts]
[exhales]
- THEY HAVE FAMILIES
AND JOBS.
THEY ARE HUSBANDS, SONS,
AND UNCLES.
THEY LIVE DIFFERENT LIVES,
BUT THERE'S ONE THING
THEY ALL HAVE IN COMMON.
[soft guitar music]
♪ ♪
- IT'S NICE
TO BE YOUR OWN BOSS,
BUT I-I DO GET
A LITTLE STIR CRAZY SOMETIMES.
I MEAN,
THIS IS EVERYTHING.
THIS IS WORK,
THIS IS HOME, THIS IS,
YOU KNOW,
MY BREAK ROOM.
I TRY TO STAY
PRETTY DISCIPLINED
ABOUT KEEPING IT
A WORK ENVIRONMENT.
YOU KNOW, I WISH THAT
I DID HAVE SOME COWORKERS
TO JOSH AROUND WITH
AND, YOU KNOW...
[inhales deeply, exhales]
WORK SHOULD BE
A LITTLE BIT FUN TOO.
♪ ♪
- SEE, I GREW UP
IN THE '60s, WHICH WAS--
IT'S AN EXCITING TIME,
AND I LOST MY VIRGINITY
AT THE LIBRARY AT BERKELEY,
WHICH WAS EXCITING,
AND IT WAS DISGUSTING.
THE PONYTAIL LETS PEOPLE KNOW
THAT ALTHOUGH, YOU KNOW,
I'M A DEFENSE ATTORNEY,
I-I'M NOT SO SERIOUS, YOU KNOW?
I--[laughs]
I'VE BEEN KNOWN
TO BE A PRACTICAL JOKER.
I'LL HAVE A GRANDE MOCHA LATTE,
HOLD THE ONION, HOLD THE MAYO.
- EXCUSE ME?
- I AM A MARTIAL ARTIST.
UH, I'M ALSO
A REPTILE ENTHUSIAST,
BUT I AM, UH,
I'M NOT COLD-BLOODED.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU ATTACK ME,
OR IF YOU TRY TO SNEAK UP ON ME,
YOU'RE GONNA FALL PREY.
MY FAVORITE MOVIES
WOULD BE A TIE OF, UH,
ANY BRUCE LEE MOVIE.
I AM, UH, SINGLE.
UM...
ONE OF THE FIRST TEACHINGS
IN BUDDHISM IS, UH, YOU KNOW,
VISUALIZE WHAT YOU WANT,
AND THEN IT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
THAT'S WHAT I DID
WITH THESE BAD BOYS.
I SAW THE INFOMERCIAL,
AND I SAID,
"GOSH,
I'D LOVE TO HAVE THESE,"
AND FIVE YEARS LATER,
THEY WERE MINE.
- OH, GROSS.
IS THIS HAIR?
GUYS, THIS IS A SCOOP.
YOU USE IT TO SCOOP, OKAY?
THINGS ARE EXTRA DIFFICULT
BECAUSE I'M GOING THROUGH
AN ESTROGEN STORM
RIGHT NOW.
AN ESTROGEN STORM IS A FLOOD
OF TRADITIONALLY FEMALE HORMONES
THAT...[sniffles]
OVERTAKES THE MALE BODY,
BUT THESE
ARE LITTLE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE TO FACE
IN OUR LIVES.
I SOUND OFF-TUNE.
[plucking, tuning guitar]
- [playing bass guitar]
[phone rings]
YES,
I WAS PLAYING BASS.
- PLEASE, JUST LET ME TALK.
- NO!
- WHAT ABOUT MY TEMPO?
- HONEY, W--
- WHAT ABOUT MY TEMPO
FOR MY LIFE?
- NO, IT CALMED ME!
- MARK,
I WANT A DIVORCE.
- I CAN'T--I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
- SERIOUSLY, MARK--
- I WAS IN A GOOD PLACE!
[knock at door]
- HI, MRS. SANGHVI.
- YOU ARE THREE MONTHS BEHIND
ON YOUR RENT.
- YEAH, NO,
I'M WELL AWARE OF THAT.
- YOU ARE USING A DANGEROUS
AMOUNT OF ENERGY IN THIS UNIT.
- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
- UH, IF I DON'T
GET MY RENT
BY THE END OF THIS WEEK,
I HAVE TO EVICT YOU.
- OKAY, MRS. SANGHVI.
A PLEASURE TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
- THANK YOU, MR. BARRY.
- OKAY.
[exhales]